what happens when you encounter fans do
fans expect you to be mean some of them
do I find yeah some of them a lot of
people that recognize me kind of back
away
they don't come towards me they don't
approach they recoil yeah I think
because I play I play characters that
are mean I
have somewhere
on the street and a couple like came up
from behind me and they were like you're
her you're her say something mean and I
went leave me alone
and they started laughing yeah and they
didn't go away and they didn't go away
because you're giving them what they
want yeah and they just kept laughing
they were like do it again and I was
like
and they're like
and they and they loved it yeah yeah